Shadow the Tomb Raider is finally here
out September 14th and sitting next to
me as Lara Croft herself Camilla
Luddington off to everything that my
father went through my gate Trinity
exactly what they wanted I think this is
the first game where you really feel
like Lara in the beginning she was
hunted by Trinity and now she's kind of
turned into the hunter and there's an
element absolutely to her losing herself
to the quest to find Trinity and stop
them and I think that she sort of has to
refined herself in this game because
there are elements of her that sort of
she's that she's definitely the hero but
there's almost like she could almost be
the villain at the same time that's
questionable
you know there's questionable actions
that she takes and then she regrets and
so she's very complicated in this game I
don't know if we could service but you
mentioned before we started that this
was your personal favor this is my
personal favorite I haven't acted this
one pushed me the most emotionally and
physically would be my aunt so without
giving anything specific it's just
always really exciting and this game
especially getting to see the team again
and knowing that it was the third and
the trilogy it was just I don't know it
it's always exciting that's the thing
you mentioned this trilogy and I like
really wanting a million words I was
like is this like the final just one
song yeah I don't know you know I think
that when I started I did always know
that it was going to be a trilogy so
that's how I thought of it so I did
leave thinking that possibly this would
be my last my lost journey with Lara
yeah I think like every interview I
watched people in the comments are like
oh I wish she would play Laura on the
big screen on the screen do you have an
itch to play her in a live-action sense
at all I would love to but I would you
know I I get asked about the Alicia
vikander movie and I joke I would have
made a very pregnant slow Laura project
during that period of time yeah I think
I would love to but also you know I I
mean I got to be part of this and this
is so iconic to me that I feel like I've
done my part - your daughter is how old
one
she's 18 months 18 months yes so I mean
I grew up with Lara Croft as my idol
like
like telling you before my granddad
taught me how to play tomb raider 2 and
taught me how to lock the butler in the
freezer
he was so creepy are you excited for
like your daughter to potentially see
you as Lara Croft or maybe kind of girl
up with her as an icon you know I
thought about that obviously it's gonna
be a long time until she's able to play
but I I'm excited for that day when it
comes because I feel like you know there
aren't many you know female lead still
in video games and Laura to me is the
first and she's definitely one of the
first and she's so iconic that I hope
that she sort of proud that her mom got
to be a piece in it so between grays and
Tomb Raider and having an 18 month old
yes you haven't very tired yeah well we
haven't heard an update on your your
wedding planning in a while you know
what Matt and I we have been really
discussing it the past month because we
have been putting it off not on purpose
but we've just been both so busy so
we've just started talking about it and
about next summer and I will let you
know you did get married on on Burzum
Adam right now on the screen was there
anything from your TV wedding that you
were like oh I kind of want to insert
that into my what's funny is we shot our
TV wedding and a preschool Calamigos
ranch in Malibu in California and Matt
came to visit the set and he stepped on
and we're like damn because it was so
gorgeous and they do weddings and he was
like we could have done it here but now
you and Alex have taken it I mean the
whole the whole wedding itself was
absolutely gorgeous on grace so I would
have loved to I mean we joked even about
like hey should we just run down the
aisle and just quickly say our vows to
like the actor priest and be done with
it um but no it was so gorgeous there
were definitely elements of it that I
kind of wanted to steal for my wedding
but I shall make them both very
different I know your fiance's like a
grown man but what's he ever like what's
he like it was weird I was leaving that
morning and he was like bye good luck
with your wedding just what else it's a
very weird being act that's what he's
enacted to so he understands looks so
but and he loves Justin
you